una de las principales necesidades que
tiene a día de hoy la población multan
ya no es todo el suministro de bienes
básicos para para poder continuar lo que
es la vida normal dentro de estos bienes
básicos está todo el tema de las
medicinas porque
en muchos hospitales se encuentran sin
medicinas y no pueden continuar la
atención médica lo que hacemos en primer
lugar es una evaluación de las
necesidades de los hospitales y en
función de estas necesidades pues
pedimos los medicamentos que son
necesarios estos medicamentos o bien los
compramos con proveedores locales o los
traemos mediante el corredor humanitario
que hemos establecido y a partir de aquí
a partir de a partir de d
de ucrania hacia el interior por medio
de corredores seguros lo que hacemos es
importar todo de
todo ese material